字幕: Chie Kosuga
校正: Kazunori Akashi
私はですね 2008年から２年間
JICAボランティアという形で
野球の普及活動をしてまいりました
その派遣された国というのが
ブルキナファソという国です
ここの国にですね 派遣されていました
ブルキナファソという国はですね
ちょっと紹介させていただきますけど
西アフリカに位置してまして
周辺国で言うとガーナとか
コートジボワールだとか
ニジェール マリという国に
囲まれた内陸国です
もともとがフランスの
植民地の時代がありまして
公用語はフランス語をしゃべります
あと産業はですね 主な産業は農業なので
みなさん農業に従事されております
ただ世界最貧国のひとつと言われていまして
もう本当に ほぼほぼ課題だらけです
問題だらけというか本当に単純に
教育も医療も農業も産業も
すべてにおいて問題があり
今もそれは続いています
そういうところで野球を
普及しましょうという活動でした
当時はですね
私が元々そこに配属された時に
一応スポーツ省というものがありまして
スポーツ省の野球連盟に配属になりました
野球連盟があるぐらいなので
まあちょっとは環境が
あるんじゃないかなと思いますよね
野球連盟があるんですよ
じゃあ野球をする環境があるんでしょうと
思って行ってみたらですね
まず野球のグラウンドはなかったですし
野球用具もない 野球の指導者もいない
野球の選手もいない
野球連盟は資金もないという
当時 私25で
本当に どんな人生経験もないので
もうどうしようかな
でも行ったからには何かしないとということで
まずできることからやろうということで
やったのはですね
とりあえず子どもたちが
いるところに行きました
まあよく行ったのが小学校だとか
子どもたちが集まってそうな広場とかに行って
野球の体験会をするということをしました
で 子どもたちが集まります
うわーって
なんだ なんだ
なんかどっからか来た なんか中国の人間が
なんか変なボール持って
なんか棒切れみたいのでばんばん打ってるぞ
みたいなのがうわーって集まるんですよ
で おおー いっぱい来てくれる
やったあと思って
で 野球の普及活動をしてました
でもですね 野球は継続できませんでした
発展していかなかったです
理由は簡単で
野球するメリットなんかないんですよ
アフリカの子たちが野球をして
何のメリットがありますか
お父さんお母さんからすごい言われるんです
うちの息子に なんか変なボールで
遊ばしてどうすんだって
意味あんのかって 腹が減るだけだって
腹が減るだけだしうちの子はバカになるし
なんの意味もないじゃないかって
こんなことをさせる意味がない
それだったら家の仕事をさせた方がいいし
家の手伝いをさせて少しでも家庭が
少しでも豊かになれば
いいじゃないかって言われました
みなさんどう思いますか
何も言えないですよ
本当になにも言えなくて
ああ そうですねっていう感じです
本当にすごく 自分はすごく志を持って
何かそこの国にお役に立てることが
あればなと思って行ったんですけど
何もできなくて 自分ってなんなんだろうって
存在意義もないし いる意味もないし
必要とされないんですよ
であればここにいる意味がないなと思って
その時のJICAの職員の方にですね
ここで野球をするのは
ちょっとまだ早いんじゃないですかって
まずインフラ整備しないといけないし
もともとの生活の基盤となるものを
作らなきゃいけないじゃないですかって
お伝えしたんですけど
その時のJICAの職員の方が
まず何かやれって言うんですよ
いや なんかやったんですって
やったんですけど要らないって言うんですって
それは本当にもう大変で
非常に 自分の中ではもう何もできない
ネガティブなことしか考えられないので
そこから半年間は一切
自分の活動は発展もしないし継続もできない中
もうネガティブな状態しかないです
もうどうでもいいや
日本に帰りたいと思っていました
ただこの話はこれで終わらないんです
ちゃんと良いストーリーもあります
（笑）
本当にこれも この偶然がなければ
今ここにも立ててないと思いますし
この活動も継続できていないですし
私もこういう人間に
なってないと思ってるんですけど
ある子がですね 私に興味を持って
話かけてくれた子がいます
カファンド＝アミールくんって
いうんですねこの子
きれいないい顔してますよね
当時10歳の子で
私が住んでいた裏に住んでいた子で
なぜか彼はぼくに興味を持って
一緒に野球をするようになったんです
それもなぜか彼は毎日来るんです
毎日来るんですよ
毎日来てキャッチボールして
バーンバーン野球やって よしって言って帰る
で すごく彼はいい球を投げるんです
なんでいい球投げるのか聞いたら
いや石遊びしてるから 石投げてんだみたいな
ああ 石投げてるから
そんなにいい球投げれんのかぐらい
いい球を投げるんですよ
（笑）
もうほんと 毎日野球やって帰って
やって帰ってって
ぼくちょっと疑問に思って
そんなに毎日来てて
お父さんとかお母さんとかから
怒られてたりするでしょうって
大丈夫？アミールって言ったら
アミールは そんなの関係ない
楽しいからやる それだけ
だから明日も来ると言って 明日も来ました
それでアミールに
野球って９人でやるスポーツなんですよ
なのでアミールは友達いるかって言ったら
アミールはですね
友達うわって集めて 12人集めました
おおー 12人来たーと思って
よしこれでチーム作ろうって
いうふうになったんですね
で そのときの地域の名前をとってですね
チーム・グンゲンっていう名前の
チームを作りました
私はですね ようやく
活動ができるようになりました
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
あの時は本当に―
やはり人間って
必要とされないと苦しいんですよ
いる意味がないと 価値がないと
どうしても前を向けなかったりするんですね
ただそのとき 子供かもしれないですよ
12人の子かもしれないけど
彼らはぼくを必要としてくれたんです
で 一緒に野球をやったんです
遊びかもしれないです
でもあの子たちは
ぼくと一緒に野球をするようになって
それから10年の付き合いをしてますけど
そこからですね活動って大きく飛躍しました
すごいきっかけは単純です
単純なきっかけなんです
で それは何かというとですね
練習しているときにアミールが
祐太—
ぼく祐太っていうんですが
祐太 ボールってどうやったら
速く投げれるんだって聞いてきました
ぼくはそのとき知っている知識で
ああ こういうふうに体を使ったら
ボールって速く投げれるよとか
こういうふうなトレーニングをしたら
いいんだよって彼に伝えるんです
そしたら彼はそこで
それってなんでって聞くんです
答えられないですね
えっ何でって だってそういうもんだからって
ぼくは思っていたんです
でも彼は なんでそれは
そういう動きをしたらそうなるんだっていう
根拠を求めてきたんです
で その根拠をぼくは伝えることができずに
うーん なんでなんだろうって思ってました
ふと思ったのが 自分は当時25で
25年間そういえば自分は
こうやれっていうふうに言われたことだけを
やってたなって思って
ああ それが自分の親にしても
学校の先生にしても
自分に教えていただける人たちの
声っていうのは—
根拠を持ったことなんか聞いたことないなと
なんでそれをするんですかって
だってみんなそうだからって言うから
そうかと思いながらやるんですよ
でもアミールたちは 彼らって文化的に
論理的に物事を考える習慣があったので
なんでって聞くんです
答えられずにいました
そこからちょっと
自分の習慣を変えるようにしました
まずはですね 何かするときに対して
仮説を立てて
で それがどういう風になるかっていう感じを
野球でするんです
こういう動きをしたらどうなるのかとか
こういうふうなトレーニングをしたら
どうなるのかっていうのを
一個一個 仮説を立てて
やるっていうことをやっていくと
なんか自分の根拠が出てきているんですよ
少しずつ
これやったらこうなるから
これやるとこういうふうになるんだよって
アミールたちに言っておくと
少しずつ自分たちも納得をして
じゃあそれをやる
じゃあそれをやったらこうなるんでしょうって
だからやるよっていうふうになってって
で どんどん彼らも能動的に
いろんなことをやるようになってきました
そこから今ですね
自分たちがすごく大切にしているというのが
物語を描くということを考えています
当時はですね
何をするにしてもダメダメな国なわけですよ
できないっていうところがあったので
じゃあもう誰に教えを乞うにしても
そのとき日本人は私だけでしたんで
もう独自に考えちゃえと思って
いいんですよ考えても
誰もなにも言わないわけですから
じゃあもう自分で考えて
自分でストーリー立てて
作っちゃえばいいんじゃないかなと思って
それを一個一個 根拠を作れば
みんな納得するだろうと思って
そういう仕組みを取っていこうと
いうふうに思いました
それをやっていくと
面白いことにですね 自分たちの―
ぼくらが今すごい大事にしてるのは
未来を描くストーリー
それを逆算的に考えましょうっていう
ストーリーを考えてます
普通はなんかゴールを決めたら
じゃあそのゴールに向かって
頑張っていこうってやるんですよね
でもぼくらは ゴールを決めたら
じゃあそのゴールに達した
理由って何だろうって考えます
このゴールに達した根拠
その根拠が見つかれば
じゃあ達するわけですよねってなるわけです
じゃあその次の段階のその根拠って何ですか
こういう結果があったからとか
こういう実績ができたから
この結果になったんですっていう
根拠になるんで
じゃあその次も行って その次も行って
行って行っていったら
最終的に今の自分になるんです
その自分になったときに ぼくらは
じゃあ今のぼくたちと
未来の自分の誤差って どんだけ
あるのかなっていうのを全部出すんです
ズレがあるか どのズレがあって
要するに何を知っていて何を知らなくて
何をやっていて
何をやっていないのかっていうのを
全部出したらですね
明日やることが出てくるんですよ
そうするとアミールたちは
よしじゃあぼくたちもそれをやるよ
なぜならここに
たどり着くんでしょうっていうわけですね
で 私たちそういう未来を逆に描く
ストーリーを作ってやってます
このときブルキナファソで描いたっていうのが
ぼくたち一番最初にゴールを決めたのが
プロ野球選手を描きました
目指すものが何もなかったので
プロ野球 目指しちゃおうかって
ゴールをプロ野球にしました
そのゴール プロ野球だとしたら
その次にあるもの
じゃあ何があったから
ぼくたちはプロ野球選手になったかっていう
想像をするんですよ
もうここはも想像の世界なので
もう嘘も本当も何もないです もう想像です
その先にじゃあどんな経験をして
どんな実績ができたから
評価を受けたのかって考えるようになりました
その後に その経験とかは
どんな環境があったらできますかって
その環境の先に
じゃあどんな知識とか方法論があったら
それが進んでいくでしょうかって
いうふうに考えてやったんですよ
それを進むとですね
これちょっと映像がありますけど
これ最初の頃です
日本人もアフリカ人もみんなして
わーって野球やって
１年の中でぼくたちのプランを作ってって
グラウンドを作って
野球の環境を作って
野球の知識を覚えてっていうのを
ひとつひとつやってって行くと
あら不思議ですよ
て 思うじゃないですか
（拍手）
で この後みなさんどうなったか
これ９年前の話です　９年前です
その後どうなったかといったら
プロ野球選手が誕生する
（拍手）
左側がですね
高知ファイティングドッグスというところで
今 所属している
サンフォ＝ラシィナっていう子です
で 右側が新潟アルビレックスの
ザブレ＝ジニオっていう選手なんですけど
この２人はグンゲンから出てまして
残念ながらまだアミールは出てないんです
ただアミールはすごい重要な位置に今いまして
彼は本当に
オーガナイズする力がすごいあるので
日本語もすごい上手に喋るようになってますし
彼は彼で重要な役割をしてますけど
こういう状況を作るようなことができました
でですね 今 私
ちょっと今現在の話をしますけど
もう少しで東京オリンピックがあります
東京オリンピックに向けて
なんとですね 今年の６月に私は
ブルキナファソの代表監督に
就任することになりました
（拍手）
人生ってほんとわかんないもので
（笑）
これぼく全然描けてなかったです
10年前にあの子たちの夢は描けて
ゴールに達するんだと思ったんですけど
これは自分がこういうふうになるとは
思ってなかった
というかここにいることも
思ってなかったですし
ほんと人生って面白いなあと
いうふうに思います
で その後の絵も描いてまして
今ぼくたちが描いている
これが最後になるか最後にならないか
わかんないですけど 描いているのが
ブルキナファソでボールパークを作りたいね
これはですね
西アフリカの諸国を巻き込んでですね
ベースボールリーグを作りましょうと
アフリカ初のベースボールリーグを
作りましょうっていうのが
今ぼくたちの大きい夢なんですけど
それをどうやったら
成し遂げられるかって考えたときに
野球のグラウンド作っただけじゃ
野球はできるけどそれはリーグにならないから
街作んなきゃダメだっていう話になって
街作るって言ってもね
ブルキナファソの人たちは
まだまだいろんな部分で課題があるから
よし人材育成をしようということで
オリンピックが終わった後に
日本語学校を作って
そこでいろんな職種の方を招いて
人材を育成して
日本の企業さんとタイアップして
日本で研修を受けた後に
ブルキナファソに還元してやろうっていう
で そこからいろんな人たちを巻き込んで
ベースボールリーグを
作れたらねっていうのがあります
なんかもう なんか
ぶっ飛んでるかもしれないんですけど
見えてるんですよ
見えてるんです
（拍手）
すいません 最後になります
この10年間で自分がすごくブルキナファソで
学ばせていただいたことっていうのは
当時何もできないという
ところからだったんですけど
今思えば
何もないブルキナファソだったからこそ
自分はこうしてられるんだろうなって
思ってます
できないできない でもそれを
ちょっとこう視点を変えてしまえば
じゃあグラウンドがない
じゃあグラウンド作ったらいいじゃないですか
野球用具がないんだったら
それも作ったらいいし
指導者がいないなら育てればいいんですよ
じゃあその一歩踏み出すためには
じゃあ何をするのかといったら
やっぱり希望を作らないと
人間って前出れなくて
アフリカの人たちにしても
きっと日本の人たちにしてもそうなんですけど
何か希望があるからじゃあ明日
ぼく頑張ってみようかってなるんですね
それがあるからこそみんな豊かに
前向きになって
人生を楽しめるので
ノーノーっていうふうに みなさんいろいろと
日本にいると思うことは
あるかもしれないんですけど
日本はいろんなことが
凝り固まってしまってるんで
たまにちょっと緩やかな視点を
持っていただいて
前を向いたときに ああ これって
イエスに変わるなって思うときがあったら
あとはもう描くんです
ゴールを描いてじゃあそれを
どうやったら実現できるのかというのを
コンコンコンって考えたら
じゃあ明日一歩やってみようかなってなったら
もう人生楽しいと思います
生きてるってとても素晴らしいことですし
いろんなことを巻き込んで
いろんな人たちと一緒になって楽しい人生を
送っていけたらなあというふうに思っています
本日はありがとうございました
（拍手）